and as I get my stomach it's also like
as it was like traveling
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined By Zoe Saldana she's
an actor who lays claim to some of the
biggest box office smashing franchises
of our time from Avatar to Star Trek and
Guardians of the Galaxy on that note you
can catch her in the long-awaited James
Cameron directed and produced Avatar the
way of water which at long last is
coming to theaters December 16th Zoe
Saldana welcome to the show thank you
thank you so much I'm excited and I'm
emotional
I can I can smell I can smell the spices
before we get started how are you around
spicy food are you comfortable around it
I feel that spicy food is like horror
movies when I was younger I was a lot
more comfortable around them
and the older I get I've just become
softer and softer and I just I can't I
mean I'm okay with it my stomach isn't
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
it's good
it's kind of spicy I like it
so I can't stop reading stories about
the making of This film from the
requisite technological research to the
construction of a 900 000 gallon tank
designed to mimic the ocean's kinetics
how would you distill the experience of
blending underwater filming along with
the motion capture because from what I
understand that's never been done before
it never has but I do believe that this
is James
um James Cameron's Like Love Letter to
the ocean he's always had this Affinity
with the ocean you saw it in the abyss
you saw it in Titanic and he's always
had different angles with it especially
with the hundreds of excursions that
he's done
and he always had to wait for that
technology to exist in order for him to
manifest what was inside of his mind you
know and he did it
I was flying with this one this one
feels like you know what you have on a
Tuesday right I think yeah well you're
ready to move on what we might have on a
Wednesday this is a tropicante here in
the two spot
tropicante
okay God help me
[Music]
hmm give me a feel like oh I might be in
Jamaica
I was like brushing my teeth this
morning I'm like what if it's so like
spicy did I forget to speak English Just
Let it Fly wherever it goes this is
wherever it goes we're in the abstract
over here perfect
from your unique Vantage Point what
would you say is the biggest difference
between trekkies and then Marvel
Universe True Believers like is there a
distinction between the fan bases are
they really birds of a feather
no there there is there are differences
I think that trekkies take it far more
serious
um they're lovely
I think it was mirroring the kind of
world that people wanted to see at that
time in the 60s so it just has like a
very special place in people's hearts
and there's something really beautiful
about seeing a grandfather father and a
son
or a grandmother mother and a daughter
you know all coming together and uh and
enjoying this
um so yeah it is there is a difference
yeah Bridge uh the generational divide I
know your mom loved it and my Dad loved
it I was actually just telling telling
them on the way in like there's so many
times that I'd come home it's just oh my
dad's watching Star Trek I know on
YouTube I grew up here in New York
Captain's Log you know like my mom used
to see it in Spanish so it was like we
are here
and I remember like it was dubbed when I
was living in the Caribbean we used to
watch reruns of and it was dubbed and
I'm like oh my God this is so old my mom
loved it she used to watch it with her
grandparents
[Music]
who's Rico
I don't know but he tastes like pizza
[Music]
okay
it's not bad I'm still I'm still here I
haven't needed
my fluids I'm I think I'm good in the
driver's seat I can tell I can tell I
feel like I'm in good hands
[Laughter]
what's the most paranoid thing you've
ever seen in movie studio do to protect
the secrecy of a production like our
story is about canvas covered golf carts
and only being able to read the script
with the security guard close by are
those Hollywood urban legend or have you
experienced those things firsthand have
you been to a Marvel set sounds like you
have
feels like a cult you're like what's
going on like I'm dressed in green for
hours of makeup
we must be shooting something what is it
and that has its advantages and
disadvantages the advantages are that
you Savor this surprise for the end
and you don't ruin it and the audience
is able to have an amazing adventure
when they go to the movies to watch it
the disadvantage is mainly for the actor
because
you you don't know what you're doing you
don't know where you're going you don't
know what you're saying you don't know
what's going to happen and that can be a
little nerve-wracking
thank you
Calientes
[Music]
oh wait wait wait it's growing that's
what happens sometimes you know like
they hear you talking or something and
then they come back and kick a little
bit oh
settling in yeah yeah and then we have
kind of a cumulative effect here now
that we're approaching the Midway point
over here
this one feels like a mild like
surprise encounter with an X you know
what I mean
yeah like you're like everything is
going so well and then all of a sudden
your day goes sideways yeah
so you broke into Hollywood with your
role in Center Stage a film that leaned
on your background in ballet dancing and
when I was a kid you know breaking in a
catcher's mitt that was a ritual that we
took very seriously can you talk through
the tips and tricks when it comes to
conditioning a pair of point shoes
well everybody does it differently
there's some people that tape up their
their toes there are other people that
cut sort of like the soul the inner soul
of the shoe they cut it they cut it in
the middle just to help help with the
breaking of it so that your foot is not
the only one doing all the work
um there are other people that go to
full shebang and cut half of that inner
soul uh they're people that just beat
the crap out of their shoes and you just
hear it it sounds like a like a
carpentry class and you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on
um yeah so it's different how would you
say that your ballet background is
served you as an action star I know you
take pride it's the old it is the number
one element that is solely responsible
for my career in action in the action
genre had I not had an athletic
background I don't think I would have
explored
um action sort of movies
we're at the halfway mark
so this next one is the one that you're
kind of looking at a little nervous
about fly by Jing oh chili oil base here
crap here we go
mmm
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
this is like an ax
from the same sex actually he's
surprising you
foreign
[Music]
but going back in
it's not back here we go
all right Zoe over a crane segment on
our show called explain that gram we're
gonna Deep dive on our guests and
scramble interesting pictures that need
more context so we'll pull the picture
up over here on the monitor actually the
laptop Bill come on man trying to
tolerate the spiciness feels like
multitasking right over here no it's
okay I understand I can't imagine what
it's like to be on that side of the
table you know this guy over here just
screaming questions I love it thank you
hear from the filming of Rosemary's Baby
I love Paris it's one of my favorite
places in the world but I do remember
that was a very stressful production
because it was very rushed and
um
and I remember like just working every
day and not having enough time to rest
and during that time I worked hard and I
played hard too like I was always like
one bottle of wine a night like you know
pack of cigarettes like did you see that
scene yeah we're gonna do that one
tomorrow like and I remember thinking
like I'm exhausted you know when you go
to work but it's like it's because that
you're I was young and very immature and
I was like I shouldn't have to party so
much
it's funny that's just what came to my
mind I'm just no filter here there you
go stream of Consciousness what's the
spiciness it happens god well that does
it for explain that Graham We are on to
the back half you're doing so good so oh
is this like the hard stuff
it's gonna I'm not gonna lie to you I'm
not gonna lie to you we're gonna be
taking some steps here okay
I'm scared of this one this one's like
the Chile lingual de Fuego yep in the
sixth spot here we go
I know that face I'm making the same one
oh my God hard liquor oh thank you
Honduras thank you for this Fuego
oh my nose is running hmm okay it's
happening yeah we're in the show but
it's it's uh
it's um it's not that oh no it keeps
growing I know I'm so sorry I'm trying
to be tough but I'm like
no
so despite at one point your career is
swearing off big budget films a fun and
wild Zoe Saldana fun fact is that you've
been in three of the top five highest
grossing films of all time a feat that
you stand alone in Hollywood history do
you feel like you have some sort of
sixth sense when it comes to aligning
with these projects that end up being
just massive Global hits no it's just
it's an open heart it's just um reading
something and then meeting the director
and then knowing the cast behind it and
um
and thinking you know well as an
audience member I would want to watch
this I would go to the movies to watch
it like that's how I've made these
decisions and it's also I don't look at
action movies or movies that are meant
for a younger audience and discard them
now that I'm a mom too
um when my kids are ready to watch these
movies I'll have like major credit
at the other day if my kids still think
I'm cool until they're like 14 15.
then I'm doing something right you know
well wait till they see the way that you
house these hot sauces on down the
gauntlet and on that note [ __ ] should we
do the next one oh my God you're so like
excited to do it too look at you
this is the uh Cosmic disco here in the
seventh spot
um
there's a sweetness at first
there's like a disco alien on the cover
on the label oh my God yeah I know
it kind of doesn't stop oh well I know
oh
so I read that ahead of filming Avatar
James Cameron took the cast to Hawaii
this is like why do you want to keep
going
[ __ ] give me a second yeah yeah yeah
yeah
taking my foot off the gas oh
okay
all right keep okay let's do it you
ready you ready
so I read that ahead of filming James
Cameron took the cast to Hawaii to live
in the woods and catch fish and build
fires when you think of the exacting and
precise notes that he's given you over
the years is the one that stands out as
being you know quintessentially James
Cameron yeah go ahead take your time
I'm gonna hit one too
yeah
um a key note for me as I was putting
near natiri together and and because I
was the first person cast I was working
with all
all these people
and we were kind of building the not V
together I was a part of that team and
it just felt so great and and the way
that they walk and the way that they
turned around and things like that and I
remember one day
Jim was like you need to understand like
they don't they don't lie
it's not in their nature so that kind of
stayed with me and I tried to always
process that whatever it is that you
tell her she'll believe it and and
whatever it is that she's thinking
she'll say it and that always stayed
with me did I answer your question yeah
you did okay you did not only did you
answer it you answered it so eloquently
and I saw the way that you were battling
through that the whole time yeah
I was trying not to drool for some
reason
mouth keeps like watering and I'm like
don't drool please so not gracious
okay are we gonna do the bomb
foreign
the color of it
oh my God I'm nervous yeah there's no
place to hide
this is another level
so I'll slow it down yeah
I know
I know I know
ah
oh my God I feel like Maya Rudolph when
she played Beyonce on your show
yeah
oh my God and that'd be be very careful
oh yeah yeah
I'm working
for you and against you at both times
are you working for me I'm trying to you
know I'm trying to save the eyes I still
like it I know in these circumstances
it's not easy you know
[Music]
oh
so I know that you grew up between New
York Dominican Republic I know I know I
know it's always I just gotta I
apologize I know it's almost like I have
to apologize for the show for the
uninitiated can you explain the joys of
Dominican Chinese food it's a sub-genre
that even in New York I think is kind of
like a if you know you know
my grandmother and my grandfather used
to celebrate their anniversary in this
Chinese Cuban restaurant on Junction
Boulevard in Queens and it was there for
decades and it had the best food so they
would give you like fried rice with like
tostones you know
and uh so I grew up sort of like that
became like a normal thing my dad is a
my grandfather as a Dominican man who
worked in Argentine Pizzeria so he knew
how to make empanadas and Asados and
everything I learned to drink wine
thanks to that because you know his wine
selection was superb
and uh but I also have family that's
like half half Dominican and half
British half Mexican half Dominican half
Japanese half Dominican like so it was
always very normal for us to eat all
kinds of things
um if my great-grandmother wasn't
cooking did I answer your question I
went some you know you know what is
impressive and something I'm noting and
unique and I've been doing this show a
long time you know like before you start
you know you're really going through it
I can tell you know and I am too over
here even though I put up a stoic front
yes you're very good at it oh thank you
Zoe so but I would say it's well you
know what you're good at once you get
going though
you hit it non-stop like all the way I
talk a lot yeah but you just rip it
right through you know you go from like
bothered to then just bam like eloquent
interview answered bam stick the landing
and then damn it do we have more of
these to eat
it's so spicy it almost tastes
artificial
I know
nothing really fun anymore
no the bomb kinda messed the vibe up
kind of feels like
I don't know do you ever have that one
friend that if you went out partying
with her or him
[Music]
and you knew that around three o'clock
in the morning like this is this is too
late like we gotta go that's when they
take that last shot yeah and they're
still drunk and all you want to do is
like have a pizza take a cab and go to
bed yeah
and they're like let's do it like the
bomb feels like that yeah it's like me
like I'm that guy being like Oh we just
got one more shot two more years two
more shots two more shots here on this
show were we friends before did I drop
you
I had that one friend it's like oh my
God can you just stop come on let's go
come on let's do it let's do it you're
like it's 4 30 in the morning let's not
do anything this one was okay but you
know what the bomb ruined my taste buds
scorched Earth so I can't really taste
anything and I'll tell you
getting gassy too I think that my
stomach is like really like upset hurt
you know making it happening yeah
sending you a message processing and
it's like in my stomach it's also like
as it was like traveling
[ __ ]
this is the last ad we call it the last
dab because the tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last one you
don't have to if you don't want to I
don't know Machine Gun Kelly said it one
time like seven years ago we just kept
doing it I don't want to be the [ __ ]
right now I know I'm okay
[Music]
my stomach is like really upset
but the good news is
we've reached the Finish Line we've done
it
look on the hot ones gauntlet
still on our feet even though this one
will have kind of a build which I know
yeah you can start to I can start to see
it I'm I'm reading the many faces of Zoe
today yeah but a through line through
your career stories that take place in
space stories that take place in
Fantastical lands stories that take
place in the future and I'm curious to
close things out with your brain on fire
mouth Ablaze what is science fiction
able to teach us or make us feel that
other genres can't
um you know what is the saying that art
can imitate life
right
so
I think that
if you manifest an idea through your art
um you see it you live it enough to sort
of manifest it I think so
I I like like I like seeing us believing
so storytelling does play a very
important role in an hour evolution
so it's we have to be very careful with
the stories we want to tell
um I'm feeling good that was deep right
that was like a little deep yeah well
you know what not a dry eye in the house
after that one everybody got the hair on
the forearm standing up and you and me
Zoe the hair on the back of our necks
after taking on the hot ones Gauntlet I
can't I almost said was like what is she
doing over here no no no guys the bomb
really like did something to me I think
I'm gonna go back to the hotel and cry
well before you do that let me just roll
out the red carpet for you Zoe So that
okay this camera this camera this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
um I hope you guys uh enjoyed the
session of the hot ones
um
I I work a lot I do a lot of stuff and
there's this movie called Avatar it's
really really small movie that I did
years ago because it was so small we
just had to do it again and and do it
small again
but it's called way of water
it opens December 16th theaters
everywhere I hope you're able to enjoy
it and thank you for watching
good job
oh my God yes can I take a picture with
my phone you guys I'm literally having
like one of those out of body
experiences where like oh my God like
what's going on inside is so much bigger
than what's happening out here
[ __ ]
hot ones fans thank you so much for
watching today's video If you want to
get your hands on the season 19 hot Ones
hot sauce Gauntlet boy do I have good
news for you just visit heatness.com
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the 10 pack the season 19
hot ones 10 pack hot ones in a box
delivered right to your door I highly
recommend it it's delicious I eat it
every week
[Music]